is now chair of the defense select
committee that's Tobias Elwood hello Mr
Elwood thank you for joining us what did
you see or hear Yesterday
uh it was chaos and the country wants to
see a functioning government this is all
deeply suboptimal if we don't regroup
fast and park the Blue on Blue then we
lose not just the prospects of winning
the next general election but even
retaining a sizable opposition so let's
remind ourselves why we're here to serve
the British people who are watching this
day by day unfold and they want
leadership in my view this requires this
crisis requires a two-phase plan if we
are to prevent a collapse of government
stage one is the collective discipline
to allow the chancellor to complete his
economic update that both the markets
and indeed the nation are waiting for so
we get some stability and predictability
about energy bills about pensions and
benefits about mortgage interest rates
sorting the economy out must be our
priority and during this time I say to
colleagues that the steady very public
drip feed against the prime minister at
this moment is not in the national
interests by all means submit your
letter to Graham Brady if you're incline
but let Jeremy Hunt complete his task
because if we implode before then the
instability would lead to a run on the
pound interest rates climbing further
and it would put us into opposition for
a generation and the second phase would
be for the prime minister to show and
commit now to honestly addressing this
question of her leadership with the 1922
committee and the cabinet but after that
fiscal statement next week this would
help move the entire debate behind
closed doors rather than the
reputationally damaging public soap
opera that this is now becoming and in
worst case triggering an early general
election let's grip the situation let's
start to control the agenda
questions so what you're saying in a
very angry turn I'm picking up this
morning Mr Elwood is that you want
everything to stay as it is for now
until the 31st of October when the
chancellor delivers his latest fiscal
statement but after that all bets are
off and this prime minister could well
be out on a rear
that is where we are and that is what
needs to be done of course it's
complicated it will require a consensus
of where we go next but ultimately the
trajectory that we're currently on will
only lead into one place so we need
leadership we need resolution that's
what the party can do when it's required
But ultimately it requires Collective
discipline like I said let's focus on
what the nation wants to see right now
is about tackling inflation and allowing
our new Chancellor to present his
package of measures
your chairman of the defense committee
what does this say um to countries
overseas
well they are watching this and we
should remember that there isn't just a
domestic audience but the rest of the
world takes a huge interest in what
Britain does they like to see leadership
from us not least in what's going on in
Ukraine at the moment which could get
very bumpy indeed with uh Putin back
against the war and they are just
wondering what on Earth is happening in
this country as things unravel we need
to sort this out not just for our own
benefit but indeed for our role on the
international stage
uh to that end uh what's going on with
Ben Wallace in Washington speaking to
his opposite number there
I understand he's going to be briefing
the House of Commons today but clearly
it's moved into a very dangerous chapter
and quite incredible what Ukraine has
done who'd ever thought six months ago
that they've been able to push back the
third largest army in the world but with
Putin in a corner now calling for
martial law in those areas where he had
that sham referendum we must now ask the
very difficult questions that perhaps
we've avoided over the last 77 years
what do we do if a state uses a nuclear
weapon and I'm not sure we're quite
there in that mindset yet uh but I
understand that there's conversations
are happening behind the scenes in
fairness we cannot rely on NATO because
the consensus in NATO would suggest that
both turkey and Ukraine and uh uh um
Hungary would not agree uh with a
consensus approach it would require the
Coalition of the willing to stand up to
Russia firstly to provide a deterrent to
prevent it happening in the first place
and secondly what would our
responsibility to react B to make sure
that if this President is crossed that
we punish that reaction that retaliate
retali in the necessarily right way
um and as we've spoken about previously
uh Mr Elwood China's watching
well exactly because what happens in
Ukraine let's say a nuclear weapon is
used or indeed let's say Russia chooses
to attack the nuclear power station in
Killzone which is now being evacuated
that entire area what will the West do
China has its own intentions uh in its
neck of the woods it's watching what's
going on in Ukraine very very with
interest indeed so we set a precedent of
how we respond in this situation here
um just a quick thought before I let you
go
um
do you want Liz trust still to be prime
minister at Christmas
I've mapped out what I think I need to
happen all this talk about whether
she'll be here or not should be parked
should be taken inside behind closed
doors but the Prime Minister herself
should recognize the severity of her own
situation let's focus on getting the
economy economic package out then we can
then turn to this very difficult matter
of the leadership of the conservative
party
it's got your talk she was always Mr
Elwood thank you for joining us